2017 wurde ich von der youtube video rot
zu einer pizza challenge nominiert bei
der ich mein gesicht beziehungsweise ein
smiley selbst auf eine pizza backen
sollte und dieses video habe ich
natürlich erst vor zwei wochen entdeckt
von daher hier rico mit meiner antwort
mit drei jahren verspätung hessen hilfe
wasser gemischt haben wir noch zwei
esslöffel olivenöl die haben wir 500
gramm mehl und wir uns machen ihr gras
den teig rockstar für mich so erster
dass das thema versorgung und noch ein
dritter dann haben wir den teig was
kannst du eigentlich das klingt ja alles
eigentlich weg muss weitermachen
ich muss gar nichts freies land kochen
wiesbaden
es ist mein zweiter vorname wird schon
besser der tag nehmen
reicht dann auch noch das ist also
schöner witz ich eine stunde später hast
du redest du das 1 2 stunden später mit
coolen so zur seite einmal weg der teig
ist fertig er bleibt jetzt hier stehen
für sieben stunden und dann kommt den
kühlschrank 48 stunden dann sehen wir
uns wieder mal wieder machen damals auch
hinten um die nach rechts gehen nach
oben machen ja zwei tage später das
passiert hier
wir teilen den teig in drei teile so wie
jesus das wasser mit pizzateig gelten
genau jetzt übrigens auch zum basilikum
ist meist ist gestorben
gut ist schon schwarz ja das stand dann
auch nicht immer im wasser muss ich muss
zugeben hätte das nicht kontrolliert
dass da die ganze last wenig lasse ich
habe auch ein leben wir packen jetzt ist
wahrscheinlich ofen weil es auch mal
ganz vor der auch geht ja das wichtigste
ist erst mal dass hier nicht da ist
wie geil ist das denn machen sind jetzt
alle treten jetzt ein bisschen der stein
20 minuten zwanzig oder dreißig bis er
richtig heiß ist damit der pizzabote so
richtig nicht einfach einmal kurz
anfassen thema
verstehst du wegen geben
die wochen richtig beraten wie die wii
in den finger schneidet den kampf zu tun
ich habe mir den finger geschient ja das
ist das licht aus
das ist nicht ich schaue sie ist gut
drauf auch benutzer haben wir uns
beispielsweise gedacht dass wir selber
mozzarella herstellen wir kaufen also
kein mozzarella die man dann irgendwie
aus dem topf aus dem kühlschrank holt
oder so selbst gefangenen selbst
gefangen wird künftig aus der elbe
nehmen
man kennt ihn den typischen dasselbe so
schützen oder was jetzt machen wir hier
den pizza boden verlieren das relativ
niedrige machen nämlich einfach so das
ist einfach schon fertig gibt es
natürlich hier die tomatensoße darauf
komplett selbst gemacht auch jetzt für
paprika war heute auch so einen kurzen
schwenk machen könnte man ja so nicht
hochgeht
die avantgarde links unten ja ja
und greife nicht immer komplett von oben
jetzt praktisch warst du bist im weg die
klasse
[Applaus]
die sie jetzt schon besser aus sie war
schon gut von ihr
die war schon gut passiert hat auch mein
gesicht genannten classe und ich nicht
so jetzt sind offen niklas und noch käse
drauf
mozzarella ja was machen erstmal wir
können dem darm selbst dazu entschieden
auch noch ein bisschen mozzarella drauf
zu packen wir wissen nicht was hinter
die idee war erst mal abwarten
ich mache so richtig cool
na du hast auch mal beruflich gemacht
zwischendurch nicht das kommt nicht rein
die schwarze gab die muss die muss auch
muss die schwarz das ist wirklich
wichtig
der moment der wahrheit vor
[Musik]
und die kann man es auch komplett
besteuern also meine augen die war
deutlich zu lange drin einmal sind da
sie ja du hast du jetzt das gesicht dann
in der mitte durchgeschnitten ja ja ich
bin noch unzufrieden jetzt also dies
nicht gut das muss ich da muss ich
selber sagen lässt das war echt scheiße
also lido ich habe eine challenge
angenommen wir haben auch eine pizza
gemacht nicht nur mein gesicht drauf
sondern mit einem smiley drauf das hat
nicht geklappt
die schmecken tut so aber vom aussehen
her
ok ich stell dir jetzt fragen wie was
[Musik]
diese erste frage kommen noch ein paar
fragen also erste frage ist wie berlin
so teuer ist wie war das besser machen
mit niklas
das war sehr an günther oswald das
dritte frage ist doch gar nicht
beantwortet soja und die vierte frage
ist was war dann läge das die dritte die
dritte frage ist was war da nix zutat
auf der pizza der das mehl und die die
fünfte frage nicht klassifizierte dann
jetzt erst die vierte die vierte frage
ist wie max du deine pizza am liebsten
geschüttelt nicht gerührt ich ich ich
meinte wegen den ich mal kurz werken in
die villa wird mir dann doch ja ich
mache ja
ja aber der erste
und das fünfte frage hast du noch hunger
die leute könnten noch kommentieren
wie geil die pizza aussagen wenn ich
kommentiere dann kommentieren der tiere
[Musik]